you know Snow White Pinocchio Bambi
Dumbo they not only look different but
they move different because when you're
animating with a pencil you can just do
it whatever you want to do right now
you've got this giant tool between you
and the animation this software and
you're setting keys and you're using you
know curves and everything it's a kind
everybody's doing the same thing number
one is it possible to be distinctive on
it out of film and did you try to be
have a distinctive style on this film
and what was different about this film
in other films I think yeah I think it's
absolutely possible to I think every
film has its own style I mean you look
at stuff like lego movie or cloudy and
they are obviously really going for for
a particular style on this film we
really wanted to have sort of two styles
I wanted to do kind of what we call the
the street version which was a little
bit more of a just a caricatured reality
a little more grounded a little bit more
realistic but still caricatured much
like the characters or caricatured real
people and since it's an origin story I
wanted to start at something that was
more grounded more real and as they
build into superheroes we could push
into the superhero style and so by the
end of the film we are really trying to
push our timing push our spacing kind of
push the dynamics of of the physics of
the world in order to make it feel like
like a comic book or like like anime
since they they're very very similar in
their styles and but at Disney we also
are like I said so much about that pose
and so much about the appeal of the
character and making sure that story is
king and that we are doing everything we
can to facilitate the story they're all
humanoid characters they're all bipeds
they've been to Maine leads how many of
your animators are using live-action
reference and to what degree did they
use it to rely on it it depends on the
it depends in the animator I mean some
animators use it on every shot if they
can obviously there's certain shots
where you're flying through the air that
you can't do video reference and baymax
shots we didn't use a whole lot of video
reference although sometimes we would
but it depends on the animators
preference some will do draw will do
sketch passes and they're blocking pass
will actually be a 2d drawing pass some
will use kind of stick figures and stuff
like that and really
we don't really care it's it's whatever
allows you to communicate where you want
to go and the emotion that you want to
get across and the performance that you
want to get across as early as possible
so we can start communicating that's
really all we care about so it just
depends on personal preference we saw
very briefly those drivers by mark em
the way they actually said it a cintiq
and they then their 2d animators that
draw over three poses and glen keane
started that now those guys are the
disney DNA that we talked about getting
that's right back is that the thing that
makes still disney animation different
from any other studio or what would you
say is the thing is i think there is a
difference i think it's one of the
things i think i think drawing is is
such a huge part of our process through
the entire pipeline and in the animation
department it is is crucial it is like i
said it's though it's the only way that
we can communicate at this point i do
draw overs the directors do drivers mark
did draw vers on on Zootopia alex cooper
schmidt is doing drivers for tech annum
even and so we're really trying to push
that 2d aesthetic into our CG because i
think a lot of times with CG the
tendency is to accept what the computer
is giving you and it's very easy to go
yeah it looks pretty good and you're
done but when you draw it you make a
choice as to what exactly you want it to
look like and if you draw over and you
go well that's not what I actually have
underneath well then you're going to
have to push yourself further and so
again going back to that pose is
everything those drawings are really
going to tell you to push that pose
because are you saying that the
characters sad or are you saying that
the character is concerned and and those
are slightly different and that drawing
is going to tell you that well Zack
terrific job was animation supervisor
and your first time out pretty amazing
let's give them a hand
ok